when a conservative talks common sense
on a college campus anything can happen
things don't go as planned inside umkc's
royal hall
[Music]
[Applause]
often it's the most mundane topics that
cause the most consternation socialism
is bad babies are people men aren't
women it's this last topic that got me
in trouble most recently at washburn
university a washburn university student
organization is criticizing the school's
president for a school-wide email
condemning an upcoming guest speaker
before i ever even spoke the president
of the university jerry farley the man
who had personally signed my speaker
contract inviting me to campus
defamed and condemned me in an email to
the entire university for allegedly
spreading hate and misinformation
left-wing campus activists from
surrounding campuses organized to
protest against me
we cannot be a race
i'm so incredibly proud of our community
for coming together so quickly to show
support for the transgender community
during our time of need
they called me a threat and a danger
little old me for having the audacity to
say that boys and girls are different
and for daring to question
transgenderism as it turned out on trans
visibility day a happy coincidence or
maybe a little bit of providence for my
speech so my producer showed up to the
protest to see what all the fuss was
about and then something happened that
we didn't expect so we're meeting for
the first time in person
are you gonna be sticking around tonight
for the speaker uh i'm not gonna go
watch him
would you be interested in hearing what
he has to say
not really
i've heard what he has to say i'm good
is there anything that michael knowles
has said in the past that you are on the
other side of and disagree with that
maybe you would want to
hope that someone addresses in the
speech tonight and ask him that question
he has a fundamental dis
misunderstanding of gender of sexuality
of what any of it means i quite fake
thank you and quite frankly
my child says gender is fake and my
child is correct he has a fundamental
misunderstanding of it and he needs to
go educate himself
i'd be happy to help him you know i feel
like that that's my job as a as a trans
ally
i'm part of the lgbtq community myself i
feel like it's my job to help him and
not my trans brothers and sisters job to
help him
and he just he has a fundamental dis
misunderstanding of the way that things
work three out of my four children
actually yes three out of my four
children are trans um uh there are all
part of the lgbt four of them four out
of four yeah because finn oh fam yeah
are trans they are part of the lgbtq
community i love them i support them
why would i do anything different as a
parent and if you can't as a parent say
you love and support your children and
accept them for who they are
give them to somebody else there's
someone out there who will
it seems like the campus is pretty
welcoming is that what you guys have
experienced on campus as far as like
conversations with teachers students
that sort of thing with your beliefs
yeah
i would say so for the most part yeah
definitely for me too
so if you if you hypothetically said
like hey i believe that men are women
and that there's a such thing as
biological sex would you feel
comfortable saying that in the classroom
or campus or anywhere on campus
yeah
i'd say so i guess when you're lying
back
right a little bit
yeah
[Music]
i would say it but i i wouldn't
necessarily say i would always feel
comfortable saying that um because
obviously people do have a lot of
different beliefs and i i know of some
people that would be upset just like
either side would
can you give me a quick breakdown of the
flags here and what they are
um this one is the standard gay lgbt
pride flag
that one
around
the shorter person's shoulders that's
not under the umbrella is a modified
product flag that includes black and
brown people as well as the trans pride
flag colors their
headband is the non-binary pride flag
the one on that poster the blue pink and
white is the trans pride flag the
lesbian pride flag i see the bi-pride
flag in there as well as the standard
lgbt
general gay pride flag and they're also
carrying the pansexual pride flag the
you see the yellow pink and blue
yeah that's pansexual
my producer approached the event
organizers themselves i had actually
already interacted with one of them a
student named sierra when she had
tweeted out the posters for the protest
that she had organized against me was
there anything that you may disagree
with michael understands that he's taken
the things he said that you said you may
have like you know some books that he's
read um do anything that specifically
you feel like you're on the other side
of
yes and that's okay yeah i'd say so
definitely what uh the rhetoric he's
trying to talk about tonight i
definitely disagree with him you know
what he's talking about today um i
believe what he posted on his instagram
was the end of transgenderism for all
um i do just want to say i know you're
probably going to ask this or something
like it um
we as a group who work to put this
together do not want conservatives or
right-wing speakers to not be on campus
we want them to be on campus just the
same as liberal or left-wing students
have their events
mainly our issue is when it comes to
safety or threatens of
violence
which i think you probably saw on
twitter um definitely certain ideologies
do strike people to engage in violence
and that was just one of our concerns
but we're more than happy that he's
going to be here um we're really just
worried about the ideas that may be
pushed yeah i've been uh approached by
my fellow peers that they feel unsafe
being here with that uh narrative being
on campus and so
um yeah it's just that sort of thing
that i disagree with if he would have
talked about
anything else that wasn't considered
hateful speech i wouldn't disagree with
him being here or whatever he wanted to
speak about because i'm a fan of the
first amendment go for it but once you
directly target somebody and especially
the people that i love that's what i
have
so in theory the students have no
problem with conservatives speaking on
campus but then when you get to actual
conservatives saying actual conservative
things then they object to it as hate
speech or dangerous or violent they're
all for the first amendment in the
abstract but when it comes to a
conservative like me speaking in
practice they're against it
[Applause]
the leftist students always have a lot
to say when they're protesting or trying
to interrupt the event but they rarely
have the guts to come up and ask a
question or refute some point in my
speech
at this speech however the organizer of
the protest against me sierra
actually showed up to hear the speech
and even agreed to sit down privately
afterward for an impromptu conversation
hi
so we're meeting for the first time in
person yes but we met previously on
twitter yes when you organized a protest
of me and kind of of the the event
general yeah yeah the topic mostly but
yeah so your name my name is sierra
deiter sierra first of all thank you for
coming for coming to the talk thank you
for agreeing to sit down i suspect you
uh don't agree with me uh yeah not
entirely no yeah not maybe almost
anything just about what you spoke about
today
did
did i convince you
no unfortunately i think um i was
talking with somebody outside i think
we're on the both either end of the coin
um i think you truly do love people and
you truly have the best intentions for
people just the way you go about it is
differently you know not bad not you
know people whatever and i'm on the
other end where i just i'm like i in a
different way i love people and i want
to respect people and i want to be there
for them you know just in a different
way
that's very kind and charitable of you
to say that did you were you always
more progressive and sort of left-wing
in your views yes yeah especially when i
started it started getting into politics
yeah it's definitely been more left-wing
yeah what got you into politics um the
2016 election yeah when i was in high
school did that to a lot of people yes
so what do you study here i study
political science in spanish those are
my majors okay and so you were always on
the left
do you
have any kind of personal connection to
this issue a family member or a friend i
have a lot of friends actually on campus
and outside of campus who identify as
transgender who um had you know with the
you know end of transgender
transgenderism madness felt directly
unsafe and felt like their protection on
campus was uh targeted so that's what
kind of fueled my fire they didn't think
that i was gonna
little old me that i was gonna attend no
but uh words speak just as loudly as uh
actions so you know this sort of
rhetoric and this narrative was directly
targeting them and they felt unsafe um
you know on campus and
there is a difference isn't there
between you know someone saying
something that might offend you greatly
or might even hurt you emotionally and
someone actually uh you know physically
harming you yeah i would definitely say
there's a difference between me saying
an insult to your face or punching you
yeah there's definitely an
actual difference there so then it's
like is it productive to use the same
words of sort of unsafe or i'm you know
i think if you feel unsafe by anything
that makes you feel unsafe using that
word is fine
i but i guess that's the word at issue
right i could be the president of this
university jerry
who invited me to come here and sign the
contract personally inviting me on this
day i didn't know the day had any
significance to any sort of sexual thing
he then condemned me and said i'm a
terrible person and a horrible hateful
bigot he probably hasn't even googled me
but he just felt impelled to do that
that hurt my feelings
but i it didn't make me feel unsafe it
made me feel unwanted
not affirmed or whatever the language is
but i didn't feel unsafe um i guess let
me say so when you say the words putting
an end to transgenderism or
trying like pushing people like you did
to the audience today to be proactively
trying to stop you know a person from
having yeah an identity you know you're
your
physical actions and your verbal and
like your physical actions or your focal
actions might incite somebody to do
something very verbally or very
physically to somebody else well those
and there's a distinction that you just
granted me right so very verbally or
very physically and i i think it's quite
clear from my speech yeah i do want
people to take verbal and political
action right you vote you engage which
can be
in turn if somebody were to take actual
action be very harmful to somebody
because what do you mean by actual
action i mean for instance what i was
proposing
was that we stop indulging
transgenderism that
that it's just not it's not that
people who think they're transgender do
not exist or do not deserve to be loved
and cared for and enjoy all the rights
everyone has but that the idea just
isn't
true that that uh you know if a
person who looks like a man if i
came out and i said i'm a woman even if
i really believed it even if i realized
that it just it just wouldn't be true
and therefore it's not good to affirm
someone in something that is not true
that that was my argument and so my
argument is that it doesn't help anybody
most especially the people who identify
this one it doesn't help them
to indulgence i'm thinking of that young
woman
who stood up and said i was i felt
transgender i was doing binding my
breasts and things
and
but i actually was autistic and i was
then i was diagnosed as autistic
does that not carry any water
um
i guess
it's
um like your words and like what you're
trying to you know give people and like
to be proactively about it i wanted to
say like that still in turn can cause
somebody to do something physical to
somebody else which you mean do you mean
if they
misinterpreted something i said sure
but you can't blame me for that i'm not
blaming you that's the thing the entire
and you you couldn't blame the people in
the audience for that
you couldn't blame the university for
that
it's definitely the person you know but
it's still
that sort of like
tie into like if some like
charles charles manson thought that the
beatles were calling him to start a race
war with the song helter skelter i don't
blame paul mccartney for the manson
killings
they would be absurd to do that
wouldn't the same principle hold true
here
i don't know if i agree yeah it's like
you know donald trump being like we're
going to you know show him what we got
you know he didn't verbally say let's
store the capital but in turn
people stormed the capital because if
you have a voice and they're gonna
listen and people feel so strongly about
the opinion that you're talking about
they might go out of their way to be but
i think that's an imprecise analogy even
though you grant that trump didn't
directly call anyone to violence but
even beyond that
it seems imprecise to me because
what i am saying is that the way to love
someone and to treat someone with
respect is to tell them the truth and
that right now the transgender ideology
is harming people the people who are in
the thrall of it and everyone else who's
now being forced to lie to the girls who
have to share the bathroom with a man to
the the swimming girls who had to lose
their trophy to uh to william thomas and
so i'm saying they're all being harmed
by it we need to go all the way in
explaining transgenderism is not real
and we need to stop the legal
toleration of it the cultural
encouragement of it and that will help
everybody involved
is that
isn't that a little different than
you know storming the capital or
something
in a per se yeah until somebody takes
your words and you know runs with them
and decides to you know
eradicate you know a transgender person
i don't even know how that could happen
i do understand how someone could hear
donald trump say we're gonna go show
those
lawmakers what we mean no he didn't he
said be peaceful but i could see how
someone could misinterpret that to go so
you don't see somebody misinterpreting
your words as like
we should end this group of people there
but i didn't say no no i don't know
you're saying they would be
misinterpreting right exactly and
misinterpreting you and then going out
of their way and you know doing an
action that causes somebody harm
everything can be interpreted and then
action afterwards can still be tied down
to the line of whoever they're going to
say you know made me do it i listen to
this person whatever what not i i
suppose anything's possible except what
i would point out is i give a lot of
these talks
nobody has done it understandable we're
talking to thousands and thousands of
people and so i understand how in this
hypothetical you were describing well
these people could be incited to some
violence or something
does the fact that nothing like that has
ever happened
does the fact that you've met a lot of
these people tonight i presumably you
talked to some of them
does that change your view of the people
you know the conservatives
who make people feel unsafe or the
likelihood that something like that
would take place or does it not is does
your view on that remain unchanged um
i think with anything if the words hold
so much truth to a person
something can happen it's not
conservatives that make people feel
unsafe
it's the
the narrative that is you know that
conservatives are articulating i
wouldn't say all conservatives but
particularly yeah i'm the one it's not
the conservatives it's just me i
wouldn't say i mean there's definitely a
lot of other people who you know say the
same as you is there any way
that i could have given this speech or
that conservatives like me could
articulate the point of view that i'm
articulating in a way that would
namely that men are not women and women
are not men and we should we should stop
um indulging the transgenderism idea is
there any way that you think that one
could articulate that view
that would not make others feel unsafe
as you're saying personally i don't
think you should indulge into these
people's lives of you know them
identifying as transgender
but they're they're certainly
uh
infringing on the things that i can do
and say right in the classroom one needs
to now
respect people's pronouns
so that would be
an an onus on me the girls who now have
to change in a locker room with men who
have male
anatomy
certainly they are infringing on their
lives and their rights so
why is this only a one-way street
i wouldn't say it's a one-way street
it's i think it's all about respect but
wouldn't you say just as you would say
why can't you leave the transgender
people alone
couldn't you say to the transgender
people why don't you leave the girls
alone in the locker room why don't you
leave the girls alone on the penn swim
team why don't you leave why don't you
leave them alone
i
i don't know if that's a sound argument
if that makes sense
um i don't think those are kind of
comparable because you're talking about
pinpointing someone's like livelihood
their human right to live however they
want to i don't think people comparing
two however they want to
no i think you have a right you have an
obligation to live you know as you
should
if i wanted to be a dolphin
i wouldn't have any right to do it and i
wouldn't have any ability to but i would
respect you i would respect you and i
would hear you will you mind that would
be there for you if you wanted to
identify as adults you would support
michael the dolphin
if you wanted to yeah it's very i think
it's misguided of you but it's very
generous yeah
sierra yes thank you very much i
appreciate you guys i really appreciate
your comments of course yeah i
appreciate you talking to me yeah
sierra may not have come away completely
convinced but the very fact that she
showed up and sat down with someone
she'd previously implied was a danger
and a menace to society was impressive
she a student activist showed a lot more
courage and integrity than president
farley who did nothing more than take
fact-free pot shots while hiding in his
ivory
tower as my speaking tour rolls on
throughout the country i'm hoping to
find more people like sierra who are
willing to cross the picket line hear
what conservatives have to say and maybe
even muster the courage to talk about
these topics face to face